so you as a you know as a screenwriter
now making your directorial debut with
this character you've had to write her
journey in the weirdest order I think
you could ever think of
it's not even really back to front or
front to back it's just all over the yes
I know I don't know why I did that how
how has that been and how did that sort
of in Congress approach influence where
you ended out with this script did you
learn things from her past you were able
to bring into this pointing to things in
the future right right I you know I I
felt like we had explored the backstory
of Annabelle and sort of where she came
from an in creation so I really thought
about what's the story that I can dig
into here
when was approaching them you know the
material and thinking about it just in
you know that 30,000 foot view and but
it brought me to Judy Warren and really
digging into her character and what it
must be like to be the daughter of Ed
and Lorraine Warren and I thought having
the Annabelle be her foil as she sort of
tries to embrace what her family does
for a living would be a great story to
tell how how early on did you decide or
was it always a part of sort of the
kernel ivy idea that you would go into
the artifact room and play around with
sort of everything yeah that was very I
mean that was I think that might have
been the first thing that James you know
we approached me with and what do you
think of this and I was like oh my god
that sounds amazing
you know presents its own set of unique
challenges but to have the the haunted
house be the Warren House as opposed to
them leaving and going to find or
investigate a haunted house it's
actually all brought home quite
literally that was a really exciting and
I just saw the opportunity and potential
in that artifact room for creating
different varied scares that we could
explore and change up as we as we told
the story correct me if I'm wrong this
is a 1971 after the events of the first
country yes it's actually yeah it's it's
the the first part of that movie picks
up right where the conjuring start you
know where the conjuring the
that when they're interviewing the
nurses they bring the doll home and then
we cut to ya year later the events of
the first conjuring have already
happened with the Peron investigation
yes oh so it's about a year later so the
Warrens are starting to come on the
people's radar on the public and the
word is getting out the secrets getting
out about what they do for a living was
that tricky to drop it in the middle of
the mythology and have to work around
other demons or artifacts that might
have come and go or was it natural since
you've been with it for so long no it's
always tricky it's always challenging
we're in the movie you know that the
conjuring - you know the house is
establishing conjuring - so I knew well
I'm not gonna burn it down you know
there's things like that I guess I can't
do that so you do have to you know you
have to pay attention to what comes
later but you know we're telling the
story of you know the this - it's also
one of the reasons that I said it and
over the course of one night - you know
it says it's about very self-contained
story - you know so it doesn't feel like
it goes it doesn't Ravel too much of
what comes after or what can it what
came before great well they are about to
kick me out I have one quick question
for you of course you also have it
coming up this year everyone's very
exciting excited yeah me too
what what was your favorite part about
getting to write the grown-up versions
of those characters having already
worked with the child versions well it's
just it was just great to revisit the
character I mean we we sort of got right
into it we're writing those but you know
it's just always a joy you know to be
able to adapt Stephen King and and and
use the book as a chichi when you're
writing the script is always fantastic
and you know one of my favorite parts of
the experience as it was what the first
one was also working with the Miss yetis
yeah you know there's there's great
people there great brilliant minds and
talents and I just love I just seem to
thrive in a collaborative environment
and they're you know they're just great
teammates and and yeah so that was
really my favorite part